[Musique]
le projet learning center de
l'université paris saclay c'est un
projet qui a vu le jour dès le début du
projet campus c'est un bâtiment qui doit
se conclure sur le plateau de moulon
selon ning center pourquoi on n'y pas
bibliothèque mais andy learning center
c'est parce qu'il va également
accueillir la diagonale paris saclay qui
est la dimension science et société de
l'université est donc ce sera un lieu
d'exposition grand public c'est un lieu
numérique
c'est un lieu qui me fera la part belle
aussi à toutes les tentatives autour du
numérique que ce soit celle des start up
par exemple qui pourront présenter au
sein de ce learning center ce qu'elles
font là aussi au grand public mais
également donc des contenus numériques
et c'est un lieu particulier parce que
c'est un lieu ouvert à tous tout le
monde pourra s'y rencontrer aussi bien
les étudiants de toutes les écoles et
universités
les chercheurs des organismes de
recherche et là aussi de tous les
laboratoires de l'université mais
également les gens des entreprises aux
alentours qui pourront peut-être être
intéressé par l'université donc c'est un
projet qui aura à trois grands espaces
n'est ce pas ce qu'on appelle le forum
avec un auditorium une brasserie pour
l'aspect convivialité rencontre est donc
un patio pour aussi donc il donnera un
côté extérieur au bâtiment
ce forum accueillera les expositions et
les événements ensuite il ya un plateau
projet où il y aura des salles de
travail en groupes de toutes dimensions
de quatre personnes jusqu'à 64 personnes
avec un open space également est en fait
donc le coeur du bâtiment ce tout en
haut du bâtiment ce sera le plateau de
silence qu'on appelait c'est à dire le
travail individuel avec des collections
qu'elle soit électronique qu'on physique
et il dominera le bâtiment et donnera là
aussi sur un belvédère qui aura vu sur
l'ensemble du quartier de moulins et
dominera aussi le métro la ligne 18
donc ces trois espaces communiquerons
autour de services partagés une
programmation commune et donneront accès
dansera cessibles pour l'ensemble de
l'université paraissait khl donc ce
projet nous le construisons c'est une
maîtrise de droit de l'université paris
saclay nous sommes accompagnés par
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay et donc nous sommes en
phase étude actuellement une travaillant
sur les plans ensemble avec notre
architecte beaudoin architecture et son
partenaire mgm arquitectos les
architectes espagnols et la livraison
est prévue pour 2020
[Musique]